welcome to the writing pde solvers talk
what I'm trying to do here is show you
the interface that's under underneath of
n dissolve and how you can address that
and use that and to write your own PD
solvers if you're so inclined so it's
it's a it's a bit of an advanced topic
probably but I think still it's
interesting to see how nd self works
under the hood ok so as we saw yesterday
solving PDEs takes a few things you need
to specify a region PD and boundary
conditions solve and visualize that's
generally the steps you need to take to
do to address the PDE and you will see
that within and dissolve the steps that
I present here are probably they're
pretty similar so just for a quick recap
to see how that actually looks like
within a dissolve so I've specified a
rectangle the PD is a laplacian one
thing may be to note a bit is that for
the PD so this coefficient here is minus
1 and minus and a half just we'll see
those a bit later and then I've to
directly boundary condition so the
rectangle is from 0 0 to 5 1 so it's
rather longer and high and there's to
directly conditions 1 on x equals 0 so
the left hand side and another one on x
equals 5 from the right hand side and if
we solve that we call nd self value PDE
equals to 0 boundary conditions the
dependent variable you extend why is the
component of the region Omega which is a
rectangle and then we use plot for
something to visualize this PD so this
is the standard standard way how nd
solve works and you can do a lot with
that already so I don't you basically
talk is over so that's that that's what
what nd solve does what I'm gonna do now
is try to show a bit how that stuff
actually works inside so the first
question is a bit why do we have an
interface at all I mean
one one important point is actually to
make it understandable what is happening
within and dissolve I think and dissolve
is probably one of the largest functions
within Mathematica code wise and
complexity wise and it's good to be able
to understand what's going on inside
that interface is used to provide to
make it possible for you to extend and
dissolve and I use this same interface
if I write prototypes for new versions
of nd solve so this is exactly the same
thing I would do and you can also do
that so if you if you if you're so
inclined another important point is that
the the process of nd solve solving PDEs
is intercepted what I mean by that is
that if you are interested in getting
out the system matrices or the element
matrices or any detailed component of
the process of solving the PDS you can
do that but for that you'd need you'd
need to use this this interface so MD
solve has components basically three
steps and if you note there's a tick
here and that's on purpose so if you
write nd solve take process equations
and this off take it er eight an ND
solve process solution we will see that
in an example just now that's the three
steps that nd solve takes to solve
equations every equation is solved that
way what I'm gonna do now is I'm going
to pick out the finite element part of
that so within this process equations we
specify the region we specify the PDE
and the boundary conditions the iterate
step will then call the appropriate
solver that might be a linear solve for
a stationary problem or it might be a I
don't know maybe a TI e solver to to
solve Vidya a problem and the process
solution step will then in the end
create the interpolating function that
nd solve returns and does some other
bookkeeping so let's look a bit how that
looks like so the same equation we had
before with the nd solve value
now called and dissolve process
equations same argument and that returns
me something that we call the nd self
state object and that state object is an
entire representation of the contents of
the N dissolve solution process I then
give this process to end and the state
objector and dissolve iterate and nd
self process solution will then produce
or return the interpolating function so
this is basically nd solve broken up
into three steps and that's documented
you can you can look at the advanced
documentation that shows how to do that
right so the first part is now we're
going to look at this process equations
step that's probably the most
complicated part of what we're going to
talk about today and then later we're
going to also look at the iterate and
the process solution component of this
okay so if we now take this this any
self process equation that returns this
nd self state object and within this nd
soul state object there is a finite
element data object embedded and this
finite element data object contains all
the data that has been processed from
these equations now okay now the first
thing maybe to note here is that you can
in principle used nd solve process as an
equation processor so if you are a
commercial or even academic doesn't
doesn't matter if you're a person that
would like to write their own solver you
can use MD solve as an equation
processor so you can write the PDE s or
OD is what you have in a normal form and
extract them from nd solve and then feed
them to you solver so that would allow
you for example to write your own PDE
solver with a nice differential equation
interface so you could do something like
that just as a first thought okay so
this process equations that does a few
things so the first thing that is done
is basically variable data and solution
data are set up variable data is the
symbolic
representation of the problem so to
speak so it will have the dependent
variables x and y it will have a notion
about the region and the solution data
will have exactly the same components as
the variable data but as a numerical
counterpart so to speak and we'll see an
example of that then for the PDE there
is the function called initialized PDE
coefficients for the boundary conditions
we call the function in lies boundary
conditions and then again for the for
the proper initialization we call
initialize PDE method data and that will
initialize the finite element method
that that sounds a bit complicated and I
think I should have an example right so
what we do now is the same equation we
had before we're going to write this in
a really manual way so what I do now is
so nd salt variable data the dependent
variable and space component so the
dependent variable is U that's the same
equation dependency we had before x and
y is the independent variables of this
equation from the region this rectangle
we create we create a numerical region
and set that to the new solution data so
you see the correspondence here space is
the X&Y component and space here is the
numerical region so this x and y is
component of this numerical region Omega
so that's how they correspond these two
and the reason we don't have a dependent
variable setting here is just effect
because that dependent variable is
actually the solution we're looking for
we don't know that yet that that's going
to be populated at the later stage okay
the initialize PDE coefficients gets
these variable data in the solution data
and then you specify the coefficients
diffusion coefficient is the identity
matrix
- and the load coefficient was minus 1/2
so this these are those corresponding
coefficients of the PD equation we saw
before that generates a PDE coefficient
data data structure and we initialize
the boundary conditions in exactly the
same way variable data solution data and
the boundary conditions we specified
especially right before and that returns
a boundary condition data okay so
right and the last part we need to
initialize at the PDE method data okay
so these these three components are done
and if we look again now at the end
resolve process equation so the the
example I showed two slides before this
is the equation which returns the energy
source data object the finite element
data and if you look at the properties
of this finite element data object it
has the boundary condition data the
finite element method data the PD
coefficient data properties and
solutions and these the first three are
exactly the ones we've just generated on
a manual way with calling initialized
boundary conditions initialize PD
coefficients so you can actually you
don't have to go through that you just
use this process equation and that would
generate these data structures for you I
just wanted to show you how you can
actually even manually generate them and
we'll probably see an example of that a
bit later right so we now have we
extract these data's the PDE coefficient
data is just expected with the string
property boundary condition data and
metadata so PDE data boundary condition
data and metadata are extracted now from
this ND soft state object right and
that's the point i've mentioned earlier
so in principle you can use end result
as an equation processor if you want to
do something like that okay
now we go to the second state the
iterate state where we'll try to find
the solution of this particular PDE and
for that we have two functions
discretize PDE and discretize boundary
conditions the discretized PDE
gets the PDE data the method data and
the solution data and that will return
the discretized PDE so this process this
is actually the function that does the
real work and the same we have that for
discretized boundary conditions that
will return the discretized boundary
conditions in the next step you extract
the system matrices so the load matrix
the stiffness matrix damping and mass
matrix if you have these you see that
there's like a thousand three hundred
elements it's a vector and this is
twenty thousand roughly twenty
thousand components and a thousand three
hundred by thousand three hundred now
you need to combine the boundary
conditions with a solution or with a
sorry with a system matrix and that's
what the function deploy boundary
condition does so the system matrices
here are now modified with these
boundary condition data that we computed
before then we call linear solve that
gives us a result and now we proceed to
the next process in a solution stage
that will generate the interpolating
function and there is the function
element mesh interpolation extracts the
mesh and the result we computed within
yourself and then we can plot this so
this is this is how in now you've seen
all the steps the basic steps that any
solve takes internally to solve a PDE
stationary PDE okay so here's a summary
of all those slides of I mean it's
there's lots of stuff on the slides but
if we quickly walk through that again so
Paul and yourself process equation with
approach with the equations the boundary
conditions the dependent variable and
the specification of the region we
extract the solution data we extract the
finite element data the coefficient data
the boundary condition data here's the
method data and this function returns
the disk is discretized PDE the
discretized boundary conditions solution
data and the metadata so a basic
application example or basic music
example is would be PDE 2 matrix so that
will return me as an argument I'll give
the PDE the boundary conditions and it
will return me all these these four data
components and now we're going to do a
little bit with with that to see how
that's actually useful
so yesterday I shout nd eigen system
which is the new function coming up and
in principle you can write it with
exactly the code I've shown now so we
use this function PDE 2 matrix so here's
a time-dependent PDE the UDT laplacian
an initial condition the dependent
variable T from 0 to 1
x and y of the CIM of the component of
omega and that returns the discretized
PDE
the discretized boundary conditions the
solution data and the metadata now we
extract the system the stiffness matrix
and the damping matrix and we call eigen
system not and the eigen system but
eigen system on this on these stiffness
matrix and get the large the smallest
four eigen values and these are the four
the four values and returns and this is
exactly the same result at what end the
eigen system gives you so basically this
small function here that I've written
here is basically the core of what nd
eigen system does it's not I mean I mean
obviously there is more code inside it
to check for wrong arguments and
verifications and constructions of
solution that takes a quite a bit of
code as well but the core concept of any
eigen system is basically this so it's
not it's not that it's not that much I
mean you you you you it's doable I think
so okay I mean you could have other
stuff you could have nd singular value
decomposition I mean why not I don't
immediately see what an application for
that might be but you could do that I
mean why not nd nd singular value
decomposition that would be exactly the
same code and when you start thinking
about it well you can take this even
further I mean you can have basically
all of the linear algebra functions that
and that Mathematica offers and use
discretize the PDE can make them to
system matrices and then have nd least
squares matrix based minimization and D
whatever decomposition it could be
implemented with that so that's the
basic the basic framework for that you
want to take guess how nd how M and
integrate with the finite element method
works it's exactly the same thing it's
exactly the same thing this is not a
secret this is how the finite element
method works you take a PDE you generate
the discretization out of it and then
you can apply linear algebra to it okay
now here's another example I wanted to
show say you want to implement a new
type of a boundary condition that we
don't currently support or don't have so
what you do now so
here's the application so we have a
Laplace equation and you have anointment
values sinus XY blah blah it's not that
important actually so any solve rightly
complains about this and tells you
there's no dershlit condition or no
robin type so here's no no dependent
variable involvement so no dearly owner
Oh Robin type boundary condition was
specified and the result may be off by a
constant value that means this result
that we get here it's it's correct but
it's floating it could be it could be
lifted up or lifted down on the solution
so this is it's not it's not a fixed
solution so we want to now write a
boundary condition and write and here
and here what I've done is I've
integrated over the solution and it
gives me the value of minus 18 something
it's it's yeah so it's an arbitrary
value basically it could be anything
now we want to write a boundary
condition that actually allows us to say
this integral should be a specific value
I want to have a boundary condition set
that says this integral should be I
don't know 43 I think that's what I
chose so let's do that okay so I use
this function PD to matrix normal value
exactly the same as I entered it in nd
and into nd solve it complains in
exactly the same way but and now we just
ignore that we we don't care we extract
the load vector the stiffness matrix and
deploy the boundary conditions the ones
that are present so this one is now
deployed it's in the system matrices we
extract the mesh the degrees of freedom
and then I've written a small function
make integral constraint I specified I
want this integral constraint to have
the number forty three I give some some
some data is transferred and that
returns me a discretized boundary
condition data again now what's
happening inside here and it's I mean
it's not really it's not that important
it's not not really the point the point
I'm trying to make is that you actually
can write your own function error to
extent this we deploy this boundary
condition call in yourself make an
interpolating function of it and voila
we have an integral that now roughly is
about 43 now the integral of this of
this of this area is now about roughly
43 which we wanted so this is just
another way to extend the functionality
if you're so inclined transient PD's so
here I have let's here I have okay so
this is this comes from a chemical
application you see the red dots here
that's where a voltage is applied and
blue part is where a another voltage is
applied and you try to measure the
voltage across this this object the
application is not not not that
important so we have a mesh we generate
a measure of that and this has about
2,500 degrees of freedom that's going to
be important in just a second I call the
function PDE 2 matrix it's a transient
problem in 3d I specify some seriously
conditions and as usual I get the
dependent at the discretized PDE the
discretized boundary condition solution
error method data and I extract these
system matrices deployed the boundary
conditions and then what I do is I use
nd solve as a time integrator as a pure
time integrator so this is the
discretized damping matrix to discuss
stiffness matrix and the load vector so
this is basically what nd salt was a
method of line does so you discretize
you take the PDE convert it to a system
of OD es and then nd solve does this
time integration so that's roughly how
that that that works now this took for
this specific example this took about 21
seconds to time integrate okay fair
enough
but now I decided okay and this is the
the solution it's not yeah pictures it's
okay
but now I want to do something else so
we have the system of equations that's
2000 equations can we find an equal
system that is much much smaller but has
the same properties and yes the answer
is you can do something like that that's
something that you do with model order
reduction I don't want to spend too much
time on how that actually works so but
basically again the input is the system
matrices they're mangled around and
something magically a system comes out
that is much much smaller but has
similar
properties so I've written this small
model order reduction code I've done the
model order reduction which takes 0.2
seconds and this produced me system
matrix loads difference in damping there
are on the size of 50 and not 2500 and I
can then go ahead and plug that into nd
solve as a time and in the time
integration step and that then of course
is much much faster than the version
before so this is a way to speed up time
integration things that's another thing
you could do with that and here is a
small plot that that the solution is I
mean roughly it's okay it's not I mean
it's not super me you could use more
than 50 control points I guess but this
is I think it's very enough for that for
such a small system so another that's
another idea okay all of what I've been
talking this is a lot of material I
understand that and it's not entirely
trivial to understand that too but all
of this is documented so initialize PDE
coefficients it's documented what it
takes as arguments what it returns right
there is a an entire tutorial about
finite element programming it's a long
tutorial that explains how to use these
concepts that I've tried to show here
another thing that's might that may be
important is the finite element method
guide so that's that's a starting point
where you can can dive into the finite
element method with on various levels so
to speak yeah thank you but bats top
nonlinear PDE is it came up yesterday so
I took up the challenge I wanted to show
this today so if you want to solve
nonlinear PDEs with this it's a bit hard
but you can do it so there's two things
you need to do to solve nonlinear
problems the first thing is you need to
linearize the nonlinear problem you need
a linearization point I'm not going to
go too much into detail how to do that
but what I'm going to show is how how
you actually would how that would work
in principle so the idea is basically
the coefficients of the PDE can be any
function so what we do at a certain
point in the nonlinear iteration we
extract the data and
create an interpolating function of the
dependent variable and we insert that
into the PDE coefficients that's the
idea how to do that it's not going to be
a terribly efficient but it's a way to
prototype it I think so here's I done
that so and because fluid dynamics came
up will we want to go full throttle so
we gonna be a Stokes equation what I
have here is a region and we're gonna
have kind of an inflow and there's a
hole inside and we want to see how that
the stationary solution for this
navier-stokes problem looks like so
here's the boundary condition I set the
pressure to 0 on the outflow here's an
inflow boundary condition here that
sound how fast the fluid flows in and
write the rest here is that all other
components have zero velocity so here is
no velocity and on the edges there's no
velocity so oops oh yeah right what I've
done now is I've separated the nonlinear
and the linear component of the PDE so
the first thing we do is we solve Stokes
equation I've I've put that into the PDE
2 matrix that gives me the load vector
the stiffness matrix variable data
metadata and the components and then
I've written a small function right hand
side so the first thing it does it
interpolates over the mesh the different
components the velocity vectors UV and P
so that generates a p0 u0 v0 and then in
this in this this is a do loop and this
do loop i reinitialize the PID
coefficients and there you see for
example V 0 u 0
here's another user a p0 alright and I
reduce co2 extraction on linear parts
add them to the linear parts deploy
redeploy the boundary conditions use
linear solve increment the old T U plus
the new one
and then write I do this eight times in
the hope that it has converged after 882
patience and it's I think it's a bit
crude so I put in a print statement so
here the first residual is 0.3 the
correction is 0.38 and you see and you
see about here that's where they're not
really the non denier fun begins so we
have four zeros and it's going down to
ten and then basically in about six
iterations with we've broken the problem
problem down and so these are then the
the the solution this is the you
velocity component the V velocity
component and the pressure component one
thing I must admit I mean it's not I
mean I just choose this because I had
some code of this lying around it
doesn't make that much sense to compute
a stationary solution for the
navier-stokes equation I I admit that
but it's it's just I wanted to give this
proof of concept that you can write even
something like that and that's that's
pretty sophisticated I think so and I
think we need to go back so and these
are rocks as usual yeah thanks for your
attention